if you're in need of some meaningful
entertainment look no further than tick
tock
i was introduced to these folks and i
have been on their feeder ever since i
need to be a part of their friend group
stat take a look at the phenomenon that
is the old gays
263 million views and 2.5 million tick
tock followers these four friends from
palm springs california are an internet
sensation bill jesse robert and mick
call themselves the old gays and over
the past few months their videos have
gone viral are any of you on fleek
totally sure i just
i i know for sure i'm not on stage
whether they're trying to decipher what
the kids are saying these days boomers
got the best
or reacting to pop culture
[Music]
we're just hanging out we've fallen in
love with this fabulous foursome are you
ready for hot girl summer
girl summer i don't know what a hot girl
summer is have you ever slid into
someone's dm
slid into someone's watch
they have some big name followers too
including rihanna kristen bell and
alicia silverstone oh and oprah daily
reposts their videos regularly they may
be the old gays but they really are
young at heart
please welcome phil
jesse robert and mick also known as the
phenomenon the old gays
now bill
you say that you're like the betty white
of the group is that true
yes because i tend to be a little more
proper
and formal
but
i also have rather devious things
running through my mind
he's sick i i'm i'm there for that
um i'm a dichotomy myself
i i think you need that balanced scale
you know
little angel a little devil a little
like properness a little fun just say
being a part of this group that has
emboldened you and made you feel
like more of an extrovert more out there
more present yeah um it's just learning
more about me and these three have
helped me so much to open up and get
over my phobias and i don't care as much
about what people think about me i have
to love me first
and um
robert i was watching you on the video
that's one of your most
popular is when you're looking back at
pictures of your youth it really just i
think took people
by surprise emotionally
and
you just talked about you know
you said you wanted to be a peacekeeper
and keep things light
yes i think that's very important uh
i i try to
read people in
conversations and encounters and if i
see anyone kind of getting rattled i try
to bring humor in and
i've always been an achiever i feel good
about myself and i try to extend that to
other people oh my god and you do you
really do
now nick
yes um
i love your saltiness and i read
actually that you um said you might be
the samantha
uh
of the group is this true
first of all i would like to say
what a glamorous woman you are
thank you mick for that approval it
really means the world to me well thank
you and
you're welcome and i would like to say
yes i am the samantha
i
love it and you can tell when you watch
the videos like you're salty you're the
salty dog i know and i i'll take any man
as i can find them
um all right we're gonna go to a quick
commercial break but the good news is
we'll be right here when we come back
with the old gays so i'm here for it
we'll be right back thank goodness
[Music]
you